hello oh this room makes me feel good
it's good to see you again i love the
snatch back you look good
thank you y'all listen i couldn't i
couldn't find it today endless
and i said today of all days i'm feeling
like i'm not trying to fight this hair
i'm not trying to do anything it's the
day that i'm coming to talk about hair
and beauty norm so i think
that it was kismet for sure something
bad has happened
[Applause]
oh i'm aware it wants to take over us
look i cannot die today okay i've been
in church like 15 years
uh hey girl
and i'm gonna start with vanessa um
number one why do you think that
this story in particular needed to be
told
and why you felt like you needed to be a
part of telling this story
well justin simeon the brilliant
director and writer
reached out to me and asked me to be a
part of the film
he described it as a a
japanese uh genre horror
film using hair which was very
interesting and
innovative and never heard it before and
then he told me about my
my character and he said listen i'm
writing it but she has to be enticing
enough to make
our protagonist want to change her
appearance in order to get ahead
which so many of us have done in our
lifetimes
to move to the next step in our careers
so i thought it was very appropriate and
relevant to where we are
but also i lived in 1989 i mean i had an
album out back in the day so i knew that
that worked right
exactly so i knew bet i i had a show on
vh1 called the soul on vh1
i knew what it was like to be put in a
mold and say well you can only go this
far
well we can't really put you in mtv
because you're in this box so
i knew the world and i knew that i could
contribute
um in in my own way to to this film and
i think it's
relevant uh we shot it on film and so
again it brings it back to the 80s and
and justin's just brilliant the casting
is
amazing of course laverne is incredible
l is incredible everyone is incredible
blair underwood who i just
did a play with online last week he does
a spectacular job it's really
uh an honor to be a part of such an
innovative film
it's a little surprising for me i mean i
i guess not
incredibly surprising but it does take
me back a little bit to hear you say
i was put in a box because for for a lot
of
us and laverne i don't know if you felt
this way too
you were our standard you know of beauty
vanessa you know what i'm saying laverne
you know of course i do
yes i do i i mean i
i'm i'm trying to stay cool but like i
was
i'm obsessed with the disciplines and
i'm trying miss williams are trying to
keep it you know chill here um rest with
me today but i was obsessed and it's
funny
as i was doing i was i put on the 1989
playlist and dreaming came on and the
right stuff came on and it was like
and these were songs you know we were i
was dancing to when i was
and and in terms of beauty vanessa was
someone that i
looked to and and was inspired by um
so absolutely and but but not just inter
but the talent i think the reason
why vanessa is still here is that
vanessa
is obviously an exceptionally beautiful
woman our first black miss america
but the talent and the talent um began
to show very early
and that is why she's here on so many
different levels the talent is just
has endured you know for you laverne i
mean it's 2020
and we still you know on your social
media posts you're still trumpeting
trans is beautiful this and like really
um
fighting the beauty norms stereotypical
norms all of those
in a completely different way why was it
so important for you
to tell this story well
first of all i just wanted to work with
justin i after i saw dear white people i
was like i
must work with this man and i sort of i
tweeted some stuff and just
i started tweeting him hoping he would
see and then i met cast members from
dear white people and said can you
please tell justin
to be in this second season of dear
white people and i everyone i would meet
and then i saw him at a party and i was
like i've been sending subliminal
messages that we should work together
and then he said well i do have a movie
that i'm working on and so
then he i kind of he's he's one of two
directors i've done this with and so he
said yes and we i got the script and i
was just blown away by it and i think
for this particular story god there's
something you know the trans is
beautiful
um hashtag came out of the black is
beautiful um movement it was inspired by
that i was like what would it mean to
have
this hashtag for trans people to
celebrate the things that make us
uniquely and beautifully trans
and i was like black folks had that and
i think it's so important still
in 2020 to say that black is beautiful
and what this film i think does
particularly being a horror film i've
been thinking i've been thinking about
this this morning is that it can become
an opportunity
to heal and to have an exorcism around
the sort of intersections of white
supremacy and capitalism and how they
and the psychic trauma that they can
sort of wreak um
on on black women i think we can begin
to exercise this and this film can be an
opportunity to um
do that in a whole new way
yeah i wonder i was thinking about this
after i i watched the movie
do we ever really get out of that
indoctrination of this is what
it's supposed to be because i i'm 45 now
and
even though i feel like i'm evolved and
i feel like i can look a certain
way when i want to i still find myself
like feeling bad sometimes because i
think oh i thought the straight hair was
look i was i looked beautiful and when i
just washed my hair and it was
like kinky like i didn't think i looked
as beautiful and what's wrong with me do
we ever really get out of
that that's digging down deep into your
own self-confidence which we all
struggle with anyway the wonderful part
is we have options so you can be
straight you can be curly you can be
wavy
you can uh you know that's
the norming thank god the crown act was
just passed because
uh being a mother of four my one of my
my daughters was working
at a very prominent boutique but you
know a
base in london and she has her own long
natural hair
but uh one day she snatched it back and
and
and wore it kind of wet so you could see
waves and she got written up because it
wasn't blown out and wasn't straight
but it was waves and she had it snatched
back they said it was too ethnic looking
and this is within the last you know
we're talking last five ten years
so it's still you still get
discriminated against
even now in this day and age in terms of
corporate america
so thank god the crown act has passed
and we're making strides
but i think it's i think what you're
talking about michelle are the things we
internalize right we internalize
that it's not going to be professional
that it's not that i'm not going to be
considered attractive that i'm not going
to get the job
these are things that we begin to
psychically internalize and that's what
how sort of white supremacy works on us
and i think the work it's
for me it's a daily process of being
like okay
i exist i do exist in this world and i
want to be
there's this sort of fight to want to be
seen and to be seen
somewhere as close to myself as possible
and
sometimes it may be easier for people to
see me if i
have my hair certain um and and
ultimately this is a shell
and it's like in the shell matters but
then i think
ultimately what is what is underneath
the shell in terms of my humanity
and so sometimes it's about how can we
allow people to see us and what what is
the best way for people to see our
humanity
and ideally people should be able to see
our humanity no matter what
texture our hair is or color our hair is
or color our skin is
ideally that's not the world that we
live in that is the world that we're
hopefully
working towards and i think that is the
um that's the thing i
sort of wrestle with my own sense of
wanting to feel good in my own skin but
then also
needing to exist in the world and and
feel seen
on something yeah yeah
you put that more eloquently than i ever
could have so amen to that
and amen to the 80s fashion i know i got
to wrap up
a man to the 80s fashion of
usher's hair in the film usher's hair
that little oh he had that redhead
kingpin
gumby yes yes i loved it i loved it
thank you all so much and you all have a
lovely day and i'm like you laverne i
was trying not to fangirl too much
thanks guys so much